North America has the greatest known
diversity of freshwater mussels in the
world and they're also the most
endangered group of animals in North
America they've evolved a pretty crazy
relationship with fish the way it works
is female muscles spend the winter
buried underneath the sediment brooding
thousands to millions of larvae inside
their shells these larvae in order to
develop into juvenile muscles have to
spend a couple of days to a few weeks
living on the gills of fish so here what
we're looking at our tiny muscles that
are still inside the female and they're
flexing their little shells this is a
close-up view inside female muscle these
are rose of little packages called can
gluten eights and they've got hundreds
of mussel larvae packaged inside of them
packages of larvae are wrapped in the
membrane to make it look like fish food
insect larvae or fish larvae that other
fish might want to eat they've got a bit
of adhesive on the tail which attaches
them to rocks and they wiggle in the
current just like a real fish larvae
would incomes of fish and it snaps up
one of the larvae if you look closely
around the gills you see a little cloud
of larvae coming out the fish pulls it
into its mouth but most of it passes
over the gills and out the sides that
gives the larvae a chance to catch on to
one of the filaments of the gill clamp
tight with its shells so I took a trip
to Virginia and Tennessee to have a look
at centers where muscles are propagated
in tanks to build new populations
there's actually a lot of research
involved in figuring out how to culture
these juveniles they tag them in order
to figure out how well their efforts are
working I went with Jess Jones who's a
biologist with the Fish and Wildlife
Service this was the first time I'd ever
seen tobacco drying in a barn and we
went to the power River where his field
assistants took thousands of these
muscles and scattered them into the
river
we saw a lot of coal mining activity
trucks driving into power plants and
coal mine and coal trains for decades
this caused a problem for the muscles
because it was harming the water quality
things have improved and right nearby
that power plant was really pristine
stretch of the Clinch River researchers
here are trying to figure out how well
the restoration work is going by
counting how many muscles are in the
river so they count them they measure
their size to figure out how well
they're doing and it turns out so far
the signs are pretty good the muscles
are growing well few of them are dying
they're even finding juveniles signs
that the population is reproducing it's
a long day's work but every bit of this
helps make sure that these amazing
creatures are going to keep surviving